the Xbox one controller is pretty damn
good for well the Xbox and PC but if you
want something a little bit more out of
your controller the Xbox one elite
probably comes to mind but Razer that's
known for its PC peripherals is offering
its own high-end solution in the
Wolverine ultimate and while it's a
great piece of hardware the price will
have you thinking twice first off it's a
hundred and sixty US dollars it only
works through a wired connection that
can be a straight up turn off
considering that the elite goes for a
hundred and fifty bucks and works both
wired and wireless leave at least the
Wolverine comes with a long microUSB
cable of about ten feet but the notch at
the USB port makes most other cables
unusable the Razer Wolverine ultimate
does have some sweet features though the
analog sticks are smooth and
frictionless you can also swap out the
sticks for either a convex one or an
extended stick but you only get one of
each these pop out easily but they still
stay in place while you're playing the
buttery smooth feel of the sticks also
carries in to the shoulder buttons and
triggers which have super light
resistance trigger stops are found
behind the controller and can shorten
the throw to about half the distance if
you prefer the biggest selling point of
this controller is the six extra
programmable buttons you get two
additional shoulder buttons labeled M
one and M two and four triggers on the
back labeled M three through M six
they're super easy to program you just
hold down the left mouse button on the
bottom row press the trigger or bumper
you want to map then the button you want
it to act as and the back triggers are
easy to actuate but they don't feel as
natural as the paddles that you see on
the elite the d-pad can also be swapped
between a four-way and an eight way cap
however this design has a slight flaw
and that the cap can pop out if you
press left or down with too much
pressure the face buttons feel just like
mouse clicks while this takes some
getting used to the distinct tactile
feedback in short travel distance of a B
X and Y is much more responsive now I
played through hours and hours of
cuphead and destiny 2 with the Wolverine
ultimate and the controller was a joy to
use in cuphead being able to constantly
hold down the right trigger to shoot and
dash at a moment's notice with the left
trigger made the game a bit more
enjoyable
since the triggers have such a light
resistance I programmed the M triggers
in the back to do the special moves and
lock myself into
but their placement isn't that great for
moves that need a split second reaction
even though I have long fingers they're
not as easy to reach as I'd like I stuck
to using a for jumping and the
mouse-click feel and the face buttons
was satisfying an on point in destiny
too I programmed jump reload crouch and
weapon switching to the back triggers
and extra shoulder buttons this way I'd
never have to take my right thumb off
the stick I felt a lot more nimble and
agile I was able to react to fire back
and leap into the air or do a slide to
throw off enemies and crucible matches
as for other features it has that Razer
chroma RGB lighting around the home
button they can customize the razer
software the handles have a grippy
rubberized texture and you'll find
on-the-fly mute in volume controls on
the bottom row of buttons oh and you
can't forget the neat carrying case that
comes with the controller raisers
Wolverine ultimate is built incredibly
well and has some great features but for
160 bucks and something that only works
through a wire it's a tough sell
especially when the Xbox one elite
controller is cheaper and works
wirelessly I hope you all enjoyed this
video and if you want to see more stuff
like this stick to GameSpot calm and
watch all our game tech features where
we break down the tech that drives games
we love thanks for watching we'll see
you soon